souple et n'ai pas joué sauf au palace
bien sûr lorsqu'il est question de fêter
le dixième anniversaire de ce qui fut et
reste encore un coup le temple de la
nuit
ambiance surréaliste
elle est de circonstance ce soir au
palace un des fleurons de la nuit
parisienne dont la règle d'or est de
cultiver un certain sens du délire
il y a dix ans maintenant qu'au fil des
transformations architecturales des
fermetures et des réouvertures on
invente ici en permanence le sens de la
fête sous chacun espère se faire
remarquer tout en observant du coin de
l'oeil les invités les plus prestigieux
je suis un mec en bus donc
j'aime bien vu
nuit jamais
mon palace minuit notamment à briser mer
le nouveau grand maître de la nuit dit
qu'il vend un produit snob un public
populaire il pourrait rajouter qu'il
vend un public snob un produit populaire
et ça marche
chaque soir près de 1500 personnes se
bousculent pour parader chacun ici et
star et devient star cris ni la crise et
le quotidien d angoisse c'est le monde
de la fête
pour certains c'est la décadence pour
d'autres c'est le merveilleux
un nouvel endroit nocturne et celui de
la fête et de l'éphémère